Depuis plus d'un siècle, Marseille accueille des immigrants d'Algérie. Au début c'était majoritairement masculin, rural et kabyle.
Au fil du temps, un lien particulier s'est créé entre ces deux rives de la Méditerranée
"La plupart des gens viennent à Marseille pour pouvoir dire un jour qu'ils sont proches de "Bled" ( : Pays d'origine)
C'est sûrement dû au rapprochement des deux rives, celle algérienne et celle de Marseille - La nostalgie disparaît...
Une jambe par ci et une jambe par là, on a deux pays c'est comme avoir deux pères et deux mères... On se dit qu'on vient d'Algérie mais on n'a pas de terre ici ou là.
Quartier Belsunce - Centre-ville de Marseille
c'est un lieu où l'on se rencontre, où ils peuvent recevoir un rayon de lumière notamment au printemps ou à l'approche de l'hiver etc...
Ça leur fait du bien, ils s'assoient là à bavarder, ils se racontent des histoires anciennes et nouvelles etc...
Le mot Chibani désigne un homme d'un certain âge.
Un homme qu'il faut respecter.
Un homme sage.
Aujourd'hui, cependant, Chibani nomme plutôt ces anciens travailleurs immigrés.
Ce sont des gens qui sont en fait arrivés dans le passé. D'abord parce qu'il y a eu la colonisation.
Une bonne partie de celui-ci est arrivé dès 1920', voire plus tôt !
aussi quelques autres qui sont arrivés pendant la guerre et sont ensuite restés
Et bien sûr certains sont même restés 50 ans
Mais ils n'avaient certainement pas pensé au sort qu'après 50 ans, ils sont devenus des étrangers partout
Depuis 10 ans, la France n'a plus assez de bras pour subvenir aux besoins de sa croissance économique.
Il a donc décidé de faire appel à une main-d'œuvre étrangère plus massive
La France a toujours été un pays d'immigration
Certainement du début du 20ème siècle
Nous avons eu les Polonais, nous avons eu les Italiens après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
nous avons eu les Espagnols après la guerre civile espagnole
Bref, il ne s'agit pas ici d'un phénomène nouveau
La présence de travailleurs étrangers est bénéfique et nécessaire au développement de notre pays
Je vous ai dit que 1 million 800 mille travailleurs qui sont indispensables et qui représentent plus de 10 % de la population active
Nous avons donc un besoin économique et démographique
Mais en même temps tant qu'ils sont là il faut s'occuper d'eux
Je suis arrivé en février 53, si vous enlevez 2 mois en 1952...
Il est arrivé en 53 en février
Sur mon papier, il est écrit deuxième mois
Attendez une minute, je vais vous montrer si vous le permettez. Attendez et excusez-moi, je pense que je l'ai ici
Fiche de travail par profession salariée - à l'exception des professions soumises à une réglementation particulière
Je suis arrivé en France le 10 avril 1971
J'ai commencé à travailler le 21 avril 1971
Je me souviens que c'était un samedi
Je suis arrivé en France pour la première fois en août 55'
je suis arrivé en 1970
Je suis descendu au port de Marseille le 17 mai 1968
Quand je suis arrivé la première fois c'était en 61'
Nous n'avions rien et j'étais obligé d'aller chercher du travail
A ce moment j'ai traversé avec la carte d'identité
Pas d'attestation de logement, pas de passeport, rien de tout ça...
Je suis arrivé avec une carte d'identité française jaune
Parce qu'ils les avaient enrôlés comme musulmans français
En Algérie, la Kabylie, région déshéritée par nature est aussi la plus dense en population du pays
Un dixième de la population doit donc partir, en flux régulier, chercher du travail ailleurs
Ailleurs, c'est-à-dire en France où le marché du travail leur est ouvert comme à tous les Français
Ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est que jusqu'en 62 les Algériens étaient soumis au code de l'"indigenato"
C'était donc des sujets français et non des citoyens français
Ce code "indigène" a permis, entre autres, le déplacement forcé de certaines populations
Il faut savoir comment ils ont été recrutés : ils sont arrivés dans un village et ont réveillé les plus jeunes et les plus forts
On les pelotait, on leur faisait passer un examen médical, on leur ouvrait la bouche pour vérifier leur dentition
Ensuite, ils leur ont donné un document avec un tampon
Et puis ils ont été emmenés en camion de leur village au port le plus proche
c'est vrai que la majorité vient du milieu rural et ça a été un choc d'arriver ici
Sebti Denfir
Marié - 7 enfants
la famille est restée en Algérie
il n'habite qu'en centre ville
arrivé en France en 1961
Il est installé à Marseille en 1995
au début quand je suis arrivé
La première fois, c'était en 1961
Je suis descendu à Marseille et j'ai pris le train pour Roanne, région N°42 "Saint-Etienne".
j'avais travaillé 2 ans
Dans une ferme appelée "papeterie"
Ça faisait des gros rouleaux de papier, des gros rouleaux
Puis j'ai commencé le rotamaio, en tant que travailleur rotamaio
Ensuite, le grutier a disparu et le contremaître m'a dit: "Sabti, alors ...
À ce moment-là, je leur ai menti parce que je n'avais jamais touché à une grue et leur ai dit que c'était mon travail
Il m'a donné la grue et m'a immédiatement montré ci-dessous
Avec la boite, voici comment il faut faire, comment arrêter la flèche, comment arrêter l'échelle etc...
En 2, 3 jours je m'y suis habitué et ça m'a laissé dans la grue
Abdallah Merzoug
marié - 8 enfants
Famille restée en Algérie
il est gracieusement logé dans différentes parties de la région
il est arrivé en France lors des grèves de 1968 alors qu'il avait 21 ans
Pour travailler, vous devez être en mesure de satisfaire le patron. Cela a été compris par le monde entier
Certains jobs qu'un grand nombre de personnes refusent, je les prends car le travail ne me fait jamais peur
J'ai toujours travaillé en déplacement car j'ai déménagé de chez moi pour me rendre à Marseille ou en Bretagne
Je suis allé à Quimper, à Brest... J'ai travaillé très dur...
J'ai travaillé dans le bâtiment, dans les usines sidérurgiques car j'ai aussi travaillé en Moselle
J'étais aussi brigadier de trains "attaquants"
et quand ils ont commencé à fermer en 72', ils ont commencé à fermer des fermes en Alsace dans le nord et partout
J'ai quitté l'industrie pour aller dans le BTP, le canon et tout ça
Casa Adoma (ex Sonacotra)
Cap Janet - Marseille 15e
160 logements
Tahar Younsi
marié - 6 enfants
la famille est restée en Algérie
Il ne vit que dans le foyer pour travailleurs migrants
Arrivé en France en 1971
A 20 ans j'installais le Palli, certains que j'ai installé sont toujours là !
Quels poteaux as-tu installé ?
vous poteaux téléphoniques les boules de bois et les boules de verre
Tu creuses encore à la main avec la barre d'acier, la pelle
Il faut descendre 1m40 / 1m50
Cela dépend de la longueur du colis
Pour le ballon de 6m descendre 1m30
Le 7m descend 1m40
Et celui de 8m descend 1m50
Et cela en deux, rarement en 3
Par la main
Quand je suis arrivé en France, je ne pensais pas travailler jusqu'à la retraite
Quand je suis arrivé en France, je pensais travailler 1 an, 2 ans, 3 ans et après
Parce que je suis arrivé après avoir quitté l'Algérie parce qu'il n'y avait rien là-bas, il n'y avait pas de travail
J'ai dit plus tard qu'il y aurait du travail et tout. J'en profite pour travailler un ici et puis je reviendrai
Et j'ai commencé ma carrière là-bas
Et puisque l'Algérie est toujours restée...
Puis j'ai continué
Et après c'était trop tard
Quand tu arrives à un certain âge c'est fini
Il n'y aura personne pour me donner du travail
Chaise Maital
gérant de la résidence Adoma Littorale
Marseille 15e
Salah Amar
Divorcé en Algérie - 4 enfants
Séparés en France - 3 enfants
Il vit dans les logements sociaux pour travailleurs immigrés depuis 1977
Service militaire en France en 1961
Arrivé en France pour le travail 1966
Au début quand je suis arrivé en France je ne pense pas rester
Je suis venu travailler, mettre de l'argent de côté et revenir
Mais quand je suis arrivé alors je n'ai jamais réussi à mettre de l'argent en partie
Maintenant je vais vous dire pourquoi : il gagnait une bouchée de pain à l'époque
Tu as envoyé de l'argent à la famille pour pouvoir y vivre
Et avec le peu qu'il nous restait pour vivre ici, je n'ai jamais pu mettre d'argent en partie
Jamais
Très bientôt ces images appartiendront au passé
C'est ce que M. Pierre Sudro a décidé
Le ministre de la Construction en visite à Marseille aujourd'hui
En compagnie de Lord Aspicar, préfet des "Bouches du Rhône"
Del Signore Gaston de Fer Adjoint au Maire et tous les cadres locaux de la première industrie marseillaise
Le ministre a tenu à visiter non seulement ces rares favelas de notre ville
Mais aussi tous les chantiers en cours
Il y aura des familles entières dans ces favelas. Les draps de haut en bas et quand l'eau est tombée, ils ont mis une planche en plastique sur le lit pour qu'il ne soit pas mouillé
Et tu passes la journée à travailler comme un âne
Le 23 mai 77 j'arrivais dans ces parages
Avant 77 où étiez-vous ?
Dans les favelas ! tu travaillais toute la journée et tu pouvais te laver 2-3 fois par mois à Marseille où il y a des douches
Ce qui nous a amené ici à l'époque c'est la misère, on n'avait rien
La France nous a maintenus dans la misère
c'est la France qui est venue nous chercher pour travailler ici
Je suis resté 65 jours dans les favelas de Saint Lazare (Paris)
Saint Lazare, oui je me souviens
Dans les cabanons de ST Lazare nous vivions avec la pantigane...
Rati qui étaient comme des lapins
Combien y ont-ils dormi ?
Quatre d'entre nous avons dormi dans la chambre avec la tête baissée.
La police est entrée et a fouillé en disant : Deux dorment pas quatre ne dorment
Y avait-il de l'eau dedans ?
Rien, il y avait de l'eau dans la rue coulait dans le décolleté
Il n'y avait rien dans la caserne
Il y a encore des favelas
Progressivement remplacés par des bals où ceux qui sortent pour l'instant ne seront pas logés
Ils sont la mauvaise conscience de nos villes
Une image de la misère du tiers-monde
Pour le nouveau venu c'est une aubaine
L'hospitalité d'un parent, d'un frère ou d'une sœur du même pays ou de la même région
Le temps passe, et la misère côtoie le luxe, la boue...
Vous pouvez rencontrer des femmes en colère
Enfants beaux et occupés
Hommes portant de l'eau
Quand vient le soir
Ceux qui n'ont pas de famille, pas de centre culturel, pas de logement décent se retrouvent dans les bars
Sebti Denfir
en France à partir de 21 ans
La grande maladie que j'ai eue dans la grue
Parce que la boîte pour le guider est lourde
La grue n'était pas aussi automatique qu'aujourd'hui. Il y a la chaise, il y a les menottes
Tu étais debout toute la journée
Et mettez la flèche là-bas, il faut mettre le verre devant...
Il y a 4 verres et 4 portes
Et j'étais trop fatigué pour que la maladie demeure. Ma jambe est enflée parce que je suis debout toute la journée
J'ai chargé la boîte avec les boutons pour conduire la grue, qui était aussi grande,
Avec des bretelles...
Lors de la visite du médecin du travail sur le chantier,
c'est lui qui m'a fait arrêter
Il a dit "c'est pas normal, ton gaba est toujours gonflé
Il a grondé le contremaître
Et il leur a dit : « comment ça marche ? Sa jambe est toujours enflée et ça ne se voit pas !
Pension de famille Labadié
(les pauvres frères)
Marseille 1
12 logements individuels
Tahar Chekkour
marié - 3 enfants
la famille est restée en Algérie
vit à la pension Labadié
Ancien habitant d'Adoma Littorale
arrivé en France en 1962
à l'âge de 17 ans
J'étais à Paris, j'étais à Guadalupe, j'étais un peu partout. Ingliterra et puis j'ai pris le train donc par hasard
J'ai trouvé "Aime La Plagne",
Je suis intéressé...
Et à partir de là, je me suis installé.
j'ai travaillé dans la restauration
Sacha Distel m'a mangé aussi,
Alain Delon, Guy Roux...
Dorothé a mangé avec moi
à l'époque ...
Quelle folie
Voici maintenant une vie de ....
mais maintenant ils sont Chibani
Quand je pars là-bas
Je suis un algerien
Non!
je suis un immigré
et quand je reviens ici
tu es un "bougnoul"
(: définition péjorative des maghrébins)
quelle connerie, c'est stupide
mais je ne suis pas en colère contre la France, j'aime beaucoup la France
tu as eu combien d'opérations ?
18 opérations ! la mauvaise graine ne meurt jamais
Votre date de naissance?
En 33, je suis né en novembre 33
20 novembre ?
en 33 !
Tu es encore jeune
j'ai 80 ans
je suis toujours jeune
Je ne dors pas bien et je ne sais pas pourquoi
Parce qu'il est en train de trop réfléchir
Ah oui en effet !
il faut s'arrêter et réfléchir !
Il faut vivre !
quand tu réfléchis tu ne dors pas
Mohamed Fodil
déto "casquette"
divorcé - 3 enfants
la famille est restée en Algérie
habite la maison Adoma Littorale
arrivé en France en 1955
à l'âge de 16 ans
Algérie
le drapeau berbère
Les Berbères Kabili
Je me suis engagé dans l'armée française pendant 5 ans
il y avait de la misère dans le village
alors je me suis engagé pour nourrir ma famille
j'ai vendu ma tête
Hé bien oui ! La France vous a acheté !
Si tu es mort, tu es juste mort pour le drapeau
J'ai sauvé 50 Français, moi !
c'est grâce à moi qu'ils sont en sécurité !
c'est pourquoi j'ai obtenu un diplôme.
C'est le drapeau, il faut le respecter !
Il y a des hommes qui t'ont défendu
Seulement mourir sous un autre drapeau
Quand je pense à ça, je commence à penser
L'équipage en manœuvre, le pessi en batterie !
restez et écoutez-vous!
restez et écoutez-vous! parler!
Oui, j'ai passé toute la guerre de mon pays en France
mais nous aussi avons été obligés de payer
Sinon ils nous tueraient
nous payons aussi !
Au FLN, comment ils appelaient ça !
Ahmed Benbott
marié - 3 enfants d'ici 2 morts
la famille est restée en Algérie
Il ne vit que dans des HLM
premier jour en France de 1953 à 1962
Il revient en France en 1966
J'étais en Bretagne à cette époque
J'étais aussi jumelé avec un mignon breton
J'étais heureux comme un roi
J'ai rencontré cette femme en 54,
Comme il était malheureux, nous avons trouvé un appartement et vécu ensemble
Je travaillais, elle travaillait et nous étions heureux comme des rois, c'était le deal.
j'étais jeune
mais je m'en souviens toujours car il y a des choses qui sont restées gravées dans ma mémoire
Les gens m'ont demandé et je suis contre la violence, mais il faut dire qu'il y en a eu des deux côtés
Sans parler de ce que les Harkis ont
les français les ont abandonnés
et les Algériens qui les ont assassinés
Torturé, j'suis contre tout ça, j'suis contre la violence
6 ans après l'indépendance de l'Algérie
Dans le cadre d'un accord franco-algérien
Signé en décembre 1968
il y avait une clause qui permettait
Aux travailleurs algériens en France pour faire venir leur famille
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réunification familiale.
Pour être admissible, il y avait certaines conditions
Avoir un salaire décent et stable
et un logement qui ne soit pas insalubre
Parmi ces Chibani qui n'ont pas fait de regroupement familial.
Beaucoup ne pensaient pas rester, et pour d'autres ils ne remplissaient pas les critères requis, les salaires n'étaient pas suffisants
Malheureusement, nous pouvons voir aujourd'hui
Que 50 ans plus tard ils sont toujours là et seuls
Si un vieil homme vous dit que
il s'entend bien avec ses enfants et sa femme là-bas,
dit buggies, parce que ...
quand ils étaient petits
On travaillait ici, ils nous voyaient une fois par an, ils ont grandi avec leurs mères
Ils n'avaient pas l'habitude de nous voir
Alors quand ils auront grandi
resté le même
Mon père était là et il m'a laissé ici
mes enfants m'ont dit plusieurs fois
Ils m'ont dit "tu n'étais pas avec nous"
Un petit boulot pour subvenir aux besoins de toute la famille et des enfants, qui à la fin se retrouvent seuls
ça fait tellement mal, tant pis !
ça fait très mal !
j'avais deux garçons à l'époque
je voulais les prendre
ma femme ne voulait pas venir
J'ai dit "faites comme vous voulez"
J'habite en France
Je préfère vivre ici seul
J'y vais de temps en temps, une fois par an ou tous les deux
et maintenant ?
Maintenant, il accepte de venir
entendu !
mais après 50 ans
c'est un peu trop tard
car je n'ai plus les moyens
ne force
faire ce que j'ai fait à l'époque
J'étais désolé, que je ne sois pas resté comme les autres ou que j'ai amené ma femme ici pour rester ensemble ici
au moins je suis resté avec ma femme et mes enfants ici ou là-bas
je suis désolé maintenant
Je ne pouvais pas profiter de mes enfants
mais maintenant j'en profite un peu avec les petits-enfants
Je prends ce que je peux comme temps avec les enfants
Êtes-vous fier de vos enfants ?
Oh oui ! ils sont bons !
Quand je reviens, tout le monde me dit que j'ai des enfants comme ça (Y)
Cela seul suffit
alors a-t-il enfin une certaine satisfaction de toute façon?
Oui, mais ce n'est pas moi qui les ai élevés, c'est ma femme
Ce n'était pas moi, j'étais là !
Hamena Ban Abdelaziz
dit "Ramdane"
Marié - 8 Enfants
la famille est restée en Algérie
Il habite la maison Adoma Littorale
Arrivé en France en 1951
à l'âge de 18 ans
ce n'est pas une vie
trop trop difficile
Pensez-vous souvent à votre famille ?
Oui !
Vous manquez ?
Chahira m'avait dit :
- vous irez passer l'Aïd el Kébir
je ne sais pas si je peux y aller
je suis fatigué et faible
je ne peux pas marcher
J'ai des enfants qui ont leurs enfants
je suis grand-père
et malheureusement
Je n'y suis pas retourné depuis 10 ans
on s'appelle surtout avec les filles
ils ont cet amour pour les aliments pour bébés
et les petits-enfants qui m'appellent "papy on a besoin de toi"
Nous serions ravis de vous voir
nous t'aimons et tout
Ça réchauffe le cœur, c'est une bonne chose mais pas un choix
ne vois pas mes petits-enfants
parfois ils me demandent au téléphone « grand-père mais tu reviens quand ?
il y en a aussi un qui m'a demandé un train. Je leur ai demandé ce qu'il voulait et il m'a remis un train !
Je leur ai demandé s'ils voulaient un train de marchandises ou un train de voyage et ils ont dit n'importe quoi...
tout cela n'est pas facile, tu plaisantes un peu avec ces choses mais ce n'est pas facile
moi aussi je commence à m'exciter
quand je pense au temps passé ici je n'ai pas vécu avec ma famille
car au final je prends très peu
Je peux aussi vous dire ce que je prends actuellement comme pension
je prends 140€ par mois
comment vivez-vous avec 140 € par mois ?
cela me semble impossible
ce n'est pas facile mais on gère
Abdel doit être retenu !
Leurs familles ne les connaissent que par rapport à la retraite
Pour l'argent qu'ils rapportent
uniquement par rapport au côté pécuniaire qu'ils parviennent à ramener à la maison
Pouvoir faire vivre cette famille un moment
Sinon ils restent toujours des étrangers pour eux
ils rentrent chez eux et ne se sentent pas chez eux
ils viennent ici et se sentent même rejetés
parce qu'ils ne savent ni lire ni écrire, ce qui est toujours un gros handicap
et pour tout ce qui concerne l'administration ils doivent s'étaler plusieurs fois
Ils restent souvent incompris
de ce côté, ils rencontrent ici de nombreuses difficultés
Cela leur cause tant de problèmes ici ..
Vous avez 1300 € sur votre compte ici
Ah ok...
- Voulez-vous que je leur donne un remboursement complet?
comme vous voulez...
non c'est comme vous le voulez monsieur c'est votre argent ! Suis-je celui qui décide ?
«Suis-je le patron?»
"C'est moi qui décide ?"
Mohamed Fodil
3 filgi en Algérie
L'un est policier, l'autre électricien
et l'autre pas encore, je leur ai envoyé 1000€ l'autre fois car il va se marier
il m'a dit "je manque d'argent"
Ai-je encore dit ? J'ai travaillé pour vous 74 ans
et maintenant vous demandez encore de l'argent?
c'est vous qui devez me donner de l'argent, ce n'est plus moi à vous !
Je n'ai pas de pension comme les autres. 120 € par trimestre et c'est tout.
Parce que mon premier patron où j'ai travaillé avant, j'ai travaillé 7 ans et il m'a donné la paie et tout mais il est resté 3 ans sans me déclarer.
et je n'avais jamais été malade pour le savoir
Il m'a donné mon salaire et tout alors j'ai pensé que c'était déclaré
et quand j'ai pris ma retraite
Quand j'ai travaillé ici, j'ai finalement réalisé qu'ils étaient des voleurs
Je pensais qu'il me déclarait travailleur
et enfin quand ils m'ont déclaré apprenti
C'est là qu'est le défaut quand on ne prend pas la même pension que les autres
car un apprenti et un ouvrier ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
Quand je suis arrivé de "Bled", je ne suis pas venu apprendre à travailler ! Je savais déjà travailler, j'étais un ouvrier qualifié !
ce qui explique leur faible pension
c'est qu'au départ ils ne pensaient pas rester
ils sont venus travailler
gagner de l'argent pour pouvoir vivre et surtout faire vivre la famille au village
et toute la dimension retraite et administrative
il a été mis de côté
certains n'ont pas conservé de documents tels que divers certificats de travail ou attestations de travail
et d'autres ont été victimes d'employeurs peu scrupuleux
mais en France il y a des aides ou avantages dont ils peuvent bénéficier
sous certaines conditions,
rester un minimum de temps sur le territoire français
Donc,
c'est un dernier rapello de la CAF
(: organisme social FR)
avant une action en justice
La CAF vous demande de rembourser 3 660 €
parce qu'ils ont vérifié son passeport
où ils ont ensuite conclu que vous avez passé plus de 6 mois dans le village
c'est vrai que je suis resté à la maison, seulement ça
tout d'abord je suis resté parce que ma femme est malade
la petite fille est malade
donc je suis resté à la maison pour faire les courses, préparer à manger à la maison
et comment dois-je faire?
6 mois ...
Oui, je suis resté 6 mois !
si votre femme est malade, ne restez-vous pas à la maison ?
si votre fille ne marche pas?
il ne mange pas, c'est moi qui leur ai donné à manger
et comment faire?
Alors les voilà qui les calculent depuis 2010
ils leur demandent de rembourser l'allocation logement que la CAF leur octroie pour les années 2010, 2011 et 2012.
puis ils lui demandent de revenir pour 3 ans d'aide au loyer (APL)
il faut mettre toutes les cartes en ordre
Que ce soit du médecin, de l'entreprise, de la banque...
tout est là !
maintenant nous mettons tout en ordre, année par année
Voici une autre boîte qui dit qu'ils ont payé trop d'argent de 15 491 €
Mais ouais ...
Hé bien oui...
la pension pour laquelle vous avez payé le devis
était de 323 €
puis ils t'ont ajouté
une dotation supplémentaire
soit 395 €
cette allocation supplémentaire, si vous partez plus de 6 mois à l'étranger
ils te l'enlèvent
depuis 53 ans que j'étais ici pour travailler...
j'ai travaillé partout
et maintenant ils me demandent "donne moi 3000"
où puis-je les trouver 3000?
plus de 3000 Dames, car il y a aussi 15000
vous devez 19 000 €
Je leur donnerai, c'est mieux si je vais me jeter à la mer
ou sinon je peux me jeter sous une voiture...
c'est trop! tous ces documents sont à moi ... où vas-tu ...
ça vient de ma fille
- est né en 87, quel âge as-tu ?
26 ans avec un handicap psycho-médecin et sourd-mutta
votre état de santé vous met en état d'invalidité à 100%
Hé bien oui...
il allait dormir tu vois.
quand je suis parti il m'a appelé "papa! .."
mais c'est quand même sympa
- oui elle est jolie, quand même...
Siège de l'AMPIL
Action Méditerranéenne d'Insertion Sociale par le Logement
Marseille centre
les petits déjeuners ont été mis à disposition des sans-abris, pour ceux qui séjournent en hébergement d'urgence
c'est un lieu qui accueille des personnes isolées et c'est aussi un lieu de prise de contact avec cette population
ce que vous devez savoir, c'est que non seulement ils ont une pension
mais que beaucoup de questionnaires leur sont envoyés tout au long de l'année
ou faire des vérifications à domicile
pour vérifier que je suis bien ici sur le territoire
il suffit donc que la personne âgée ne voie pas ou ne réponde pas à l'un de ces questionnaires
ou qui n'est pas présent à son domicile
considérer que je suis potentiellement un fraudeur fiscal
puis ils arrêtent et suspendent l'argent
pendant longtemps il y a eu l'idée qu'il s'agissait de tricheurs potentiels revenant
Ils ont pris l'argent et sont partis dans leur pays
J'ai été à Notre Dame de la Garde
Je suis allé la voir en tant que militaire
j'ai apporté des bougies
et j'ai pleuré
quand je me suis endormi, j'en ai rêvé
et elle m'a dit
- "Je suis derrière toi ..."
c'est notre mère,
La mère de nous tous.
c'est une réserve où l'on peut mettre des choses
y compris les affaires des résidents qui sont partis ou décédés
malheureusement c'est le cas d'un homme qui est mort dans le village
nous ne connaissons pas sa famille en France
et personne n'est venu demander ses affaires
à part pour les documents
livret de famille
relevés bancaires
toutes données possibles sauf ses effets personnels
quand je vois ces cheveux, je pense au résident de l'homme, à la personna...
je voulais garder
quelque chose de personnel
et cette question n'était pas là de la famille ...
dans sa chambre il y avait ses cheveux bien rangés contre le mur
une photo, d'identité
dans un tout petit cadre
c'est un livre
"une vie"
par Guy de Maupassant
ce monsieur avait un côté amoureux
parce que quand il a dit que s'il devait rentrer il ne l'a pas fait, il l'a dit parce qu'il a embrassé son fils pour la première fois quand il avait 14 ans
quand une personne d'un certain âge le dit en pleurant
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très fort et symbolique
c'est touchant et résume un peu la solitude
la souffrance
tout ce qui caractérise un peu ces hommes